[Music]
and welcome to the gsb we are so excited
to have you here for view from the top
so excited great
well before we start i want to do a
quick poll so please raise your hand if
you have done a 23andme test before
wow okay you have a strong market base
here at the gym but there's a lot more
that could be
i like i i see no i see opportunity
left a survey at the end to see how many
people are going to get it now
so i have done 23 and me as well and i
just wanted to ask you one question
about my test results okay so
i do a lot of customer care support
so should i be concerned that my results
said that i have more than 92 percent or
i've
92 more neanderthal dna
than the average customer what is that
about that is a fun fact that you should
share at all parties okay um
it's actually the neanderthal report
is
is kind of an example of some of the
things that we've done where
we try to make genetics and frankly like
try to make all of science relatable
make it something that's fun for people
um so honestly one of the first things i
was at a a ted dinner once and we were
talking about there was craig vent like
all these famous genetics people and
they were talking to a bunch of tech
leaders and um they were talking about
like the latest results in one area or
another and then
um i brought up something about
asparagus and how you can smell it in
your pee and 45 minutes later people
were still talking about the asparagus
and the pee question
and i realized like people want
scientific information that's like kind
of fun kind of the cocktail party
conversation
and something that's interesting so
neanderthals was absolutely like one of
the interesting parts like it teaches
people about science and then it does
become one of those things like people
are always comparing like
i have so much neanderthal like what
does that mean and what should i do
about it so it's definitely it's
interesting but no it's a it's a proud
fact that you should post widely on
everything yeah thank you i hope you can
all find your i think that's why you got
in
yeah actually i think so thank you
well since we're already talking about
23andme i'd love to dig in a little bit
more so i'm amongst and many of us here
are amongst the 12 million users
and i'd like to take us back to day one
actually how did you convince that
initial set of customers to buy a dna
ancestry kit
well we didn't convince very many people
um
we
had i'd say like one of the things
that's great about 23andme and that was
also a shortcoming in those early days
like we're incredibly strong on the
science
and i had two scientific co-founders
from stanford who had just finished
their phds
and they had joined and we created
essentially like the product we dreamed
of like
how can i peruse my chromosomes and look
at all the different reports and see
what they mean and like
explores like kind of them like academic
fantasies
and we have like we have a product now
called ancestry composition in the early
days we had these pca plots and it was
like
it was relatively technical and hard to
see um
and we thought it was all great and so
we did no marketing
research at all so like from a business
school perspective like we did not
assess market demand we just kind of
made the hypothesis like of course
everyone wants their genome like of
course everyone's going to want to get
it so
it was academically like very
interesting and it was controversial so
we were the front cover of we were above
the fold front page of the new york
times when we launched um amy harmon
wrote the article it was the only times
new york times has ever written sort of
a first person account of like them
doing a product um we're the cover of
wired thomas getz wrote that piece
um so we got tons of coverage
and the first day we sold a thousand
kits
and um after that
we sold like
it trickled down to like 10 to 15 kits a
day
and
um and we didn't have any marketing team
we just kind of assumed it would be word
of mouth it was a thousand dollars
and the value proposition was not
clearly there it was like really sort of
an academic product so that was kind of
the first moment in the company we're
like huh
we might have to do a little bit more
product market research here um to
figure out what's going to drive sales
but i think the first customers that we
got were really people who
um are sort of the quantified self world
like the people who just want to test
themselves on everything and i would say
you know there's like a market of 50 to
100 000 people who are just like i want
to try it all
and those were the people who were
coming our way who happened to also have
the spare thousand dollars um but it was
it was pretty brutal
um
that the first few years
yeah that's that's very interesting and
so now you found product market fit you
found all these amazing customers
well i would say we're still finding
product market i mean i think what's
interesting for me
with genetics and i don't know
you know healthcare
i mean it's such it's so interesting
because gsb like you guys have founded
so many
amazing companies and the tech world has
really come from here and there's all
kinds of areas that have been really
revolutionized but healthcare is this
last frontier that has not really been
evolved
and um
and the reality is like it's not just
like it's this frontier it's like kind
of like a different solar system
um
healthcare doesn't operate in the same
way like it's not you know we all use
healthcare but none of us are the
customers
like you're just the means for
generating revenue but like somebody
else is paying the bill so it's really
challenging to change and it's also
incredibly fragmented
so in the tech world when there's a new
technology that comes out
it's rapidly it's usually rapidly
adopted like you look at like the you
know what's happened with machine
learning and tensorflow and all these
things that google puts out like it gets
adopted relatively fast and the human
genome was sequenced
you know 20 years ago
and i would say
how many people have had their doctor
recommend that they
get their heat their genome
and use it outside of pregnancy or
outside of cancer like it's almost none
and so part of the issue we have right
now is like genetics has still not been
adopted by the existing system and
there's all kinds of laws for that
reason so for instance doctors
you know there's no profit motive for
people to get this information
so a doctor does not make money
if they give a diagnostic and so there's
good things about that like you don't
want them excessively recommending but
for that reason as well like no one is
really motivated to create extra work
for themselves so when i think about
product market fit
there's still this huge chasm between i
have lots of consumers who are frankly
like really eager to do more
and take more ownership of their health
but the healthcare world's really not
set up in any capacity to help them
execute on that and so you know doctors
are not trained on genetics doctors are
not used to you know people coming in
with more information and frankly
prevention is not a reimbursed
you know part of medicine it's like not
like if you like figuring out how you
can exercise or how you should eat
better is not something that you get
from your doctor you get that on your
own but frankly like that has that's a
huge component of all kinds of
prevention
so we're still working on product market
fit and how you actually create a new
industry that frankly is direct to
consumer and how you're inspiring people
to take more ownership of their own
health but it's also an out-of-pocket
expense
yes
i think that's a very humble answer you
have 12 million customers which is
amazing i'd like to talk about those
those 12 million because obviously
selling kits is one part of the business
but then when you have these 12 million
plus customers there's a swath of data
of course that that comes along with
that and massive opportunity in the
therapeutic space
so i'm curious as you're moving to
focusing really on that data
what gets you excited about all that
data well
i mean this that that is like for me
when i think about like starting the
company like that was a huge part of my
incentive and my dreams
i find it fascinating that we all have
like all of life comes from a really
simple code
so for those of you who are engineers or
you know coders like
it's just it's like
mind-blowing to me how remarkably simple
you have an ac g and t
and that accounts for all of life
on this planet
and um it's like small variations like
you and all of us are 99.5 percent the
same
and i always tell my kids like you're 50
banana
and you're like 90 mouse so like you're
very similar to everything like it's
remarkable to me
that we don't understand
this code
so i think about
like every night you go to bed and like
your body just everything works it's
like you live in this
incredibly complex system
and we have no idea how it works like i
just to me this is the ultimate puzzle
it's like really like and as a kid it
used to just keep me up at night like
how does it all
happen
and and even things like how all of your
cells can differentiate and like how
they turn out like i just it's
mind-blowing to me um
so
by understand by having a large amount
of data
we're starting to understand what does
the human genome mean and you have some
really like simple examples so for
instance like one mutation causes
whether or not you have dry ear wax for
wet ear wax like another really fun
medical example um but the the reason
why we put out the dry ear wax in the
wet earwax kind of report is because it
teaches people that you can have like
one simple genetic variation
and that can cause a different phenotype
like a different trait and so what's
really interesting for me is by having
13 million people almost 13 million
people and billions of data points is
that we're starting to make sense
of the human genome and frankly like
this should translate one day like when
you have billions and billions
it should translate one day is like how
do you actually really understand the
code of life and that's really for me
like the ultimate goal here is like you
want to understand it
and when i think about drug discovery
my background when i was investing on
wall street was in biotech
and biotech's a really like it's amazing
because the science is so interesting
but from an investing perspective um
like there's one well-known investor
he's like and i love biotech he's like
90 of everything fails i just short it
all and
and
and like that's true from an investment
perspective there's some reality to that
like statistically most of it's going to
fail but for me it's like i want to
create things that are going to work i
want to create things that are actually
going to have an impact on people so if
you start with human genetics you are
more than twice as likely to be
successful so
one of my hopes here was like to bring
structure and you know a new kind of
approach to drug discovery so more of
those drugs would actually succeed and i
again i think about my dad's a physicist
we mentioned my dad's particle physics
like my dad used to always complain he's
like oh you biologist like it's so
confusing you're such a disaster it's
like so it's like all over the place
there's no structure and you know
there's some truth to it like it's
really complicated um and physics has
its laws and its principles so for me
that's like part of the goal is like in
some ways once we have enough data how
do you bring enough structure so that
then you could really have very rational
drug design and actually be able to have
a much higher success rate
one unique aspect of the data that you
have is there is a self-selecting aspect
to it a lot of most of the data that you
have is people who have signed up for
the kits so how do you think about that
when you're making pretty large
generalizations potentially about the
data that you have well we get this a
lot about like what's our bias and again
coming from wall street and looking at
all clinical trials and say i've never
seen a data set that doesn't have a bias
so it's not bad that we have a bias
the important thing is to know what it
is and to be able to identify it and
then you account for it so i would also
say now
that we are
you know so large
we have pretty amazing representation
and diversity of all site of all types
within the data set so we now and that
was part of the push we had for 10
million is like at 10 million you get
you know a lot of statistical power to
do analysis on on most disease areas
so
there's absolutely always
a bias because we are self-selecting
it's people who are paying um you know
lowest entry point is a hundred dollars
um but we do attract people for very
different reasons and i would say the
ancestry customers which also do consent
for research you know coming in at a
lower price point and are also
interested in a different type of
product than my health customers
so i would say again like my main thing
is with data is it's important in some
ways just to go for size like size
really is the number one thing that
matters and secondly it's like really
understanding your limitations but not
like there's no such thing as the
perfect data set right well your
intention around women and other
disadvantaged groups and getting data
around them is so important because
there are not enough medical studies uh
done on women and and people in other
groups and so is that something that you
think about as well as we do we think a
lot about i mean most genetic studies
have been done in european populations
so
that's one of the other things like we
are still majority european
within 23andme but the fact that we are
um you know 20 30 of 23 me is
non-european
that makes us the largest in the world
of non-european genetic studies so
there's things that we can do
um that absolutely will attract and
encourage more you know certain
populations to come in and i think
that's something that's more and more of
a priority for 23andme is to make sure
that we're you know attracting not just
a european population but a very broad
population and just to emphasize i think
people don't realize um in some ways
like studying africa
is
is one of the most important and
exciting opportunities in genetics
because there's more diversity in africa
than there is in the rest of the world
and so
there's going to be a tremendous number
of really interesting genetic insights
that come from there so we're reaching a
point
um there's been all kinds of you know
challenges before with the complexity of
studying different populations but we're
getting to a point where we actually
really have that opportunity
to do a lot more in every population and
we think about ourselves even as we put
out a report how do we hold ourselves to
a bar that we're not just putting out
content for a european population but
putting out content for all different
communities
i'd like to go back to what you were
saying about marketing and how it wasn't
initially a huge focus um and in 2013
you unexpectedly got a note from the fda
to discontinue marketing of the tests we
do a lot of crisis management case
studies here at the gsb and i'm curious
if you did who was your first call and
what advice did they have for you oh
good question i um
i love so that's like it's definitely
one of the parts when i speak at rob
siegel's class it's like one of the key
things i love him asking the students
like oh was it silicon valley arrogance
or ineptitude
i love always hearing people talk about
us and i just did another taught the
innovators dilemma where like also like
there was really this sense is like oh
you were so inept
um and
um and so what people don't realize on
23 we did get a warning letter um
i'm almost proud as it like it was one
of the most well-read warning letters
ever um it was it was definitely um it
would and partly it was it was um an
unusual warning letter because it was so
angry
um
what's interesting is when 23andme was
started like i said we were very
academic
um and one of like we were also very
like because we were academic like we
actually had we hired joanna mountain
who came from stanford she was an
assistant professor here we had an irb
like we thought through
we thought through a lot like we engaged
with
ethics like hank greeley who still
doesn't really love us but we engaged
with him um like we were like i've been
like i come from an academic background
like i love debate like tell me more
what can i do what's like where am i
wrong so we totally engaged and one of
the first people we had called was david
kessler who was the former commissioner
of the fda so he's like clearly very
experienced
he was a professor at ucsf and he pulled
together his whole
team like his senior advisors from when
he was in the administration and we sat
down we're like are we a medical device
and we really debated this like it was a
whole debate with his team like what
like what are we and um concluded we're
not a medical device
and you know in those early days it was
kind of a question like you have the
right to own your genome
like it's your data like same way you
have a right to look in a mirror like
that's your image like you have the
right to have it so you have the right
to have your genome and in my mind all i
was doing was like connecting you to
publicly available literature like that
seemed
totally reasonable um
so in those early days we concluded
we're not a medical device and um and
then we even met with people like von
schenbach who was also at the f who was
actually the fda commissioner at the
time and he was super clear you are not
a medical device and we will not be
touching you and regulating you and one
thing that was like a kind of a
political wake-up call and like just a
company wake-up call is that when um
obama was came into office
like that changes everything and the
leadership of the fda changed and they
said like no you are not
like you know outside of our reign of
regulation like we are going to regulate
you
and so it was an overnight kind of shift
like we had just been told for years
that we were not going to be regulated
and then it became very clear like you
you're not just going to be regulated
like we're coming we're coming
now so
um the first
so i got the letter on a friday and then
i had the weekend to sort of think about
it and my typical stance i was like oh
it's not such a big deal um
and then they made the letter public
and kessler called me
and he called me and he said anne i know
you and i know you're not paying
attention
and
um and i'm telling you now that it's a
big deal
and um and it was it was you know we had
the company really had to pivot
and i had no shortage of people
like there was a article fortune wrote
called 23 and stupid
um i had no shortage of people you know
like well-known geneticists who are like
you know you it's time for you to step
back and let us clean up your mess
like no shortage of people who love to
come and be like the woman with no
degree like i was really screwing up the
industry
and um
i had one really great mentor and it was
a regulator um also a woman who said ann
you have two choices like do you want to
sell the company i was like no she's
like well then you put your head down
and you just do the work like get the
work done she's like but i'm telling you
now it's gonna take you five to ten
years
and um and we were lucky because we had
cash we had that ability i found an
amazing leader to do it and frankly it
was the best thing for the company
because i think one of the most
important things 20 to me has proven out
is that consumers actually can get
genetic information
and most
healthcare providers i would say tend to
assume that you're not capable
of changing your behavior or
understanding complicated information
and we have now successfully really
proven out that like you can understand
really complex
concepts and we had to prove to the fda
that you know over you know like a cert
at a certain grade level you know over
90 percent could pass actually like
tests
and we had to prove that with our
reports they can do that and we did and
you know we now have you know six seven
fda authorizations um we're the only
ones who have gone down this whole path
and i feel like we
like when i think about us as advocates
like one of like 23andme as an activist
brand like we are advocates for
consumers and proving out that you are
far more capable of taking care of
yourself than the healthcare system
today believes
and as you've just described healthcare
is obviously a heavily regulated
industry and many of us will be going
into other heavily regulated industries
whether it's healthcare or fintech or
what have you
i'm curious obviously you had some great
conversations and some great points of
contact but what was the best and maybe
worst advice that you got
around regulation
well it's interesting the night before
i mean like the night before i got my
fda warning letter i was actually at
a healthcare political dinner
i won't say which group but it was like
a group and they were like oh and you're
getting so stale like you should do
something more crazy
and
um i just want to say that was like a
group of like healthcare regulators etc
who are like you gotta keep pushing
boundaries and then the next day i got
my warning letter so clearly that team
was pushing in the wrong direction um
i mean look i think i think the number
one thing that um you know the best
advice we got when we had our letter was
um you know you're on the right side of
history
and so it's just a matter of time so one
thing i remind people in the company is
that when we started 23andme gay
marriage was illegal
so
the world does change
so and it changes because of advocacy
because of like people rising up and
also because of data so when people ask
like how did 23 me convince the the fda
we convinced them with data like we we
went head to head with like their
arguments and we're like we're gonna
prove out that we are accurate that
people can get it um so i think the most
important advice for people is knowing
that
um whatever the laws are now or whatever
the regulations are like things can
change and society is constantly
changing but you have to put together
the right kind of package and the right
data and the right support to drive that
change
but it's totally
mutable
one obvious big societal
change in the past three years has been
the pandemic and i'm curious how covet
19 has informed your strategy for how
23andme can engage in potentially future
health crises
well i think what was interesting during
the pandemic is we had
because we have millions of people who
are consented for research who are part
of it
very rapidly we were able to put out a
questionnaire to
customers
and
and you know collect you know hundreds
of thousands and now i think we have
like one and a half million people
who've taken our covent survey so very
quickly we were able to actually do
research on you know why are some people
getting so sick
why are some people not getting sick
like even now i'm kind of fascinated
like there must be genetics about why
some people some people must be
genetically resistant and you see that
with things like hiv hiv there's
actually a mutation where people are
resistant to getting it um
so we have the ability to very quickly
survey millions of people and get
information about them so
in this day and age like it's kind of
remarkable that there's no nationwide
surveillance system
for public health and we have that
ability now to really do that
another aspect of covid that changed how
leaders interact was i heard a lot of
ceos having text chats or
email exchanges with other business
leaders and i'm curious how you
potentially leaned on other business
leaders and what kind of maybe business
community that you formed
uh it's actually in it's been um i mean
in some ways it's been kind of nice like
i never had really the ceo business
community before but i feel like there's
now where i i do see more ceos and we
all have kind of like that same
pain point of like oh it's really hard
um
and like specifically like right now
it's really hard like it's a really
tight job market
um so people all want a lot more money
and they
you know return to office is super
complicated like is it hybrid is it in
person
everyone wants something different um
and then the stock market has really
collapsed
um
and so there's just a tremendous amount
of uncertainty and also like how do you
develop culture
in
like a zoom environment like you can't
like you all saw what it was like going
to school in a zoom environment like
it's not fun and so like being in a like
having your office be a zoom environment
is also not fun
um
so i think it's it's super complicated
so like right now it's actually really
it is fun it's kind of relieving with
other ceos to be like like none of us
really know what to do um and so there's
comfort when you know like we all have
that pain of like it's it's really it's
hard and like all the market dynamic
like everything is about being redefined
like the whole like work environments
are never going to be the same
and so
how do you really have a hybrid
environment
so that's been like the name number one
thing i think for me and even at
different policies you know talking to
companies about like what are you doing
for return to office or are you like are
people coming in like how do you manage
vaccinations like everything has been
sort of non-stop
of you know helping manage and then also
we've had all kinds of social unrest so
like also then how do you manage
um
you know george floyd and you know now
you have roe versus wait like all of
like political issues are also now
really rising up to you know really
occupy people's minds
so how do you actually you know also
have a company
and you know in in the background have
such political issues so i do think that
as the world's gotten more complicated
there's been more more bonding over
it's complicated
yeah
so much of what we learn at the gsb is
around collaboration and doing projects
together and everything so i think it's
really nice to hear that that continues
even when you're at the top
uh yeah i mean i think it's
i think it's important to always reach
out i mean i think that's one thing i
just always like i and i have to say
linkedin is amazing in this capacity
like it's so easy to connect with people
now and it's so it's it's so lovely to
go across industries so i do think that
people are particularly interested like
it's so dynamic right now people are
particularly interested in hearing
different viewpoints
so i do think there's it's like a
particularly receptive time
you mentioned company culture briefly
and every single guest that we've had on
stage has talked about company culture
it's obviously very important and how
were you intentional about setting the
culture at 23andme well i had um i had
coming from wall street and again i like
i lived in wall street during like kind
of the craziest era like 99 2000 like
most of you probably don't remember this
but it was wolf of wall street
oh yeah for sure like i have um
i mean there's like some of my
there's like experiences when i see that
or even when i watch billions i was like
so parts of billions are based on real
experiences like there was one episode i
was watching i was like i remember when
that happened like there's just like and
they got down to the specifics of
specific trades like trades and
information like it was um
it was a totally crazy time so
in some ways um
having that experience like i learned a
lot of things of what not to do
and i have one boss
who was in jail
and
you know like i start okay i so i
i always say i was like well you know
like you there's no better way to
experience what not to do than you know
living that and you know another boss
who would get so angry and would slam
phones into the wall and
so
it was also an interesting time like
watching google start
and google being
like really fun like it was super
supportive it was really quirky they
like hired my sister when she was
pregnant
people wore whatever they wanted
um
you know like they were always
rollerblading sergey and larry were
always rollerblading into meetings
um
so it kind of opened up the door like i
do credit them like they opened up the
door for having different types of
cultures and
i've never been a person who likes
veneers like i really i have this like
issue like i really hate things that are
fake
um
and so i don't like and i don't like
commercials for that reason and i don't
like um
you know like like a plastic office
place where everyone's like dressed up
nicely like i feel like it's just it's a
veneer so um so having a culture that
was authentic was really important to me
and having a culture where people felt
really comfortable
and you had diversity like we're a
genetics company like we support
diversity like the like the world is
amazing because of diversity so like we
want to support diversity um i have
always said and i realize this with
myself is like you hire extraordinary
people but extraordinary people are not
extraordinary every day
and so we're team and so for that reason
like if you get sick someone can cover
for you or if you're just like having a
bad month like
you know the team like it doesn't sink
everything and people don't get mad at
you like we are a true team
and so i've always wanted to have a
culture where we have extraordinary
people but like it's truly
supportive and we have this diversity
and
kind of like an academic environment
like you're always learning like you
have this humility of like i know
nothing like i still just said i feel
like i know nothing like i'm always just
trying to learn
um and i look at my scientists and
others like there's always really that
humility is just so important um
so i think that's like when i think
about culture it was really about
authenticity
and
you know like truly supportive and
supportive really if i want to hire
people and have them with me for 10 or
15 years you have to be flexible with
like work-life balance you have to be
flexible as people have other issues so
like a real balanced environment and one
that was like really
um like hire humble people who like are
super eager
to learn from each other and for that
reason i have like really great
marketing people who know nothing about
therapeutics
and like therapeutic people who know
nothing about
you know cac to ltv like that like it's
just it's so interesting to learn
and so i always tell people like join 23
me and you should take advantage of the
fact that you're like constantly
learning
really interesting different things so
culture for me
i think has to be really intentional um
and i think it's really important
for me to have a positive culture where
it's like supportive and i'm really
proud of like the number of people who
have left 20 through me and gone off to
start companies
um and like and especially a huge number
of women who've done it and
and they again also are really focused
on creating a positive culture
so it spreads
is there maybe a little specific norm or
practice that you think represents the
culture well
something you guys do
um
we're very focused on exercise like so i
never
dress like this i only wear it was like
a big debate for me like do i wear my
shorts um so i wear shorts t-shirts and
my running shoes every day
and i totally terrorize people who take
the elevator
and
i
i wanted to put up the signs there was a
study that came out about like hey like
you're sitting in the elevator but like
if you had just walked up those stairs
like it would have added like 30 seconds
to your life um
so i just think like for me exercise and
health like for me it's like walk the
walk like we have good food
it's healthy like we don't have soda we
um encourage like we have lots of
fitness classes um i have a huge number
of people like we have a very intense
workout culture like people love
so like we have like intro to working
out and then like more of the advanced
like we have lots of yoga
i do lots of yoga meetings
like we just like okay
we'll put the notes on the floor and
then you'd like downward dog and you
read your notes you make
hold one hand you're in plank
um i mean i think you can yeah you can
be super creative with that but i'd say
like that's
like i think a hallmark of our culture
is the authenticity like you can be you
and you don't have to
like there's no veneer that you're
trying to put on and
you know the best thing about being
authentic too is like you make mistakes
all the time
and then people frankly i think trust
you more when you make mistakes
yeah absolutely
well so many of us here are in
healthcare but many of us are not so i'm
curious from your perspective what is a
trend in healthcare today that we should
all be aware of
well i think the trend that's hard to
ignore is the rise of virtual
so when i first went to
health 2.0
um
it was like a scary set of companies it
was just
um i mean this is probably 12 13 years
ago it was like the bar like it just was
not starting yet um and there was it was
just not starting it so now
you know and even pre-pandemic we used
to meet with all kinds of companies that
were
you know virtual pharmacy or virtual
telemedicine and it was like such a
niche
and 20 through me had talked about like
should we get involved in these areas
and i was like like the last thing we
need to do is like pioneer another
whole path um
but the reality is like pandemic made
virtual a requirement
like it totally like it's um overnight
you had to start using virtual care and
you know pharmacies and laws change so i
mean there was an incredible opportunity
like this is an example where regulation
really changed and it opened up a whole
a huge sector so virtual is really
interesting the thing i'd point on is
like almost all of these virtual
companies are focused on employer and
you know health plan based care
and that to me always feels odd like if
you go and you join amazon for two years
and you're you know
pre-diabetic and you have a program like
why do you lose access to that program
if you change jobs
like why your health care is with your
employer like really doesn't make sense
to me so
part of what we've always tried to do is
like
create a world that's outside like that
you control that's outside of the system
and
i would say that another trend is that
more and more is truly going towards
your own empowerment meaning
there's an app called 21st century cures
that
empowers you to be able to get access to
all of your health records and move them
around and they're not making it fully
easy yet but it's like it's coming where
you should be able to own all of your
records
but there's also now price transparency
like there's really interesting
companies now surfacing
that you can actually like know if you
need to go and get a mammogram like what
does it cost so in the past i would call
around and try to get direct to consumer
pricing for something and it was
impossible and now it's actually like
these laws are in place to actually like
force it
so
i do i'm a huge proponent i think
there's like really
exciting direct-to-consumer worlds
and
most companies are still focused on
employer
and i would say or like the medicare
populations but i would say that there's
a huge opportunity on direct to consumer
and people it's just harder
because i think there is like a real
shift
that people have to get educated on and
i think one thing again just to
emphasize on health care and again
privacy is top of mind for lots of
people people don't realize that if your
insurance company pays for
you to do a procedure or something they
they then know that and they own that
information
so if you don't want
your physician or your insurance company
to know something then you should
self-pay
and so part of again like 23andme i
would say is like proudly
not hipaa compliant
because it actually forces us to get
your real consent versus like hipaa now
like frankly even like i'm always
criticizing stanford for this like you
don't have a way of opting out of their
hipaa form so that means they can take
like i just went to a doctor the other
day and they mandate taking your picture
and you have to sign a consent form that
they can do anything they want with it
like really like can you imagine that if
facebook's like i'm gonna take your
picture and then i have the ability to
do anything i want with it and you have
to consent for that like that's outrage
so um
i do think like people like privacy and
healthcare people don't fully understand
it
and you have gdpr and the california
privacy act like that's happened for the
tech companies but i think there's going
to be a change at some point in
healthcare people just haven't woken up
to it yet
but there's like a really terrifying
world of like how everything all your
health information is shared that you
just don't know about
that's very helpful advice
and speaking of advice
half of us in this auditorium are
actually graduating in three weeks
including myself
and many of us have been considering or
are going to be pivoting their careers
you've pivoted a few times and i'm
curious what lessons you have to share
with us
i think pivoting is the best thing ever
i think it's so
it's it's so i mean it's so interesting
to to learn different areas
like i don't know if you knew larry
lessig who used to be at stanford who
ran like internet law and then he was
just like one day like
i want to learn about corruption and he
moved to harvard and he's like i'm going
to become an expert in corruption and i
just
it's so great like to do the same thing
all the time is just boring
so to do totally different things like
the world is so interesting you should
absolutely keep pushing yourself
to just keep like pivot and do
interesting things i always encourage i
mean i i try to keep most people at
23andme but when someone's actually been
there for a while and they want to try
something else i'm like yeah you should
quit and like do something new like the
world is so interesting like never
shortchange yourself on like going and
exploring you guys are all like super
i mean
it's an amazing talent pool like
everyone can go and get interesting job
like it's you owe it to yourself to go
and have that exploration of totally
different types of careers and frankly i
think i'm i feel grateful to my parents
who
when we graduated college there was no
push to go and get a single job so like
i worked as a nanny i worked in like i
tempt i worked in all kinds of different
random areas and like all of those
experiences were super helpful
of knowing what you really want and even
obviously wall street was just a short
term for me and i think i'll be it you
know i'll be at 23andme for a while but
like i have this luxury of like i'm
always doing different things with
23andme i'm now in drug discovery more
and then personally i have you know i do
all these like real estate projects at
home
um in los altos like that's super
interesting so
i totally encourage like keep pivoting
and every experience adds up
and
you know you never know when an
experience is going to be valuable and
if it's not interesting then quit
great well that was definitely an answer
i needed to hear so thank you
definitely
well thank you anne i deeply admire the
conviction that you've had throughout
your entire career and i know all of us
here are excited to see how you and 23
and me will continue to change the world
and i have more questions but i know we
have some questions in the audience i
would like to turn it over to them great
hi my name is neil renz i'm a medical
student and a business student here
and i'm curious how you think about
balancing data privacy
patient you know patient privacy with
sharing information in a way that
advances scientific progress
i love the privacy questions
because again i think that
what i found is that most people
actually want to participate in research
so when we started the company it was
sort of hypothesized
people don't actually want to
participate in research it was almost
this mindset of a clinical trial like
get them to come in and consent for
everything because you never know if
you'll be able to really get anything
else
and i looked at things like susan g
komen and livestrong and like all this
enthusiasm to do walks like people
really actually want to make a
difference and even bone marrow drives
and such
and i go again to
some of these human subject consent
forms
where
they don't return information back to
individuals like and frankly i find them
super insulting like why like you really
like it's the paternalistic side like
you think i'm not capable
of getting this information and just to
like level that with people there's a
jama study from i think 1960
where they asked physicians whether or
not they would tell
a patient that they had cancer
and 90 of physicians said they would not
tell their patient so the world has like
really evolved and it's come a long ways
and like i think it's kudos to the
medical world for evolving but i think
that we can absolutely do more
with looking at
individuals as like a responsible
individual who can handle their
information and more as a partnership
and so like right now
a lot of healthcare providers and
insurance companies and epic they all
use hipaa as a way to not let a consumer
share their information there's always
these concerns like oh a consumer might
get their medical records and then
accidentally share it in the wrong way
um do the wrong things with it
or it might be like too much information
for them there's kind of a very
paternalistic take on it
and i've just always felt like you
should be entitled to your
information and then put it on the
individual like if you want to share it
in your ways like allow you to
share it so to answer your question
specifically like i think that there
should be transparency and i think there
should be choice
that's like the hallmark of everything
23andme does is like i'm fiercely
independent and i never want someone
telling me what to do and like the last
thing i want someone tell like my
healthcare provider should not be
telling me what to do like give me the
information
and i will make my own decisions and i
would eighty percent of our customers
opt in to research
it's not even like they have to click
out of it like they're electing to opt
in to research so i would argue that
even more people would
opt into research if it was given a
choice and that was kind of my point
with stanford like why aren't i giving a
choice
of actually like opting in or opting out
like why do i have to be part of it and
so i do think that choice and
transparency is like actually how you
build trust and i think a lot of
consumers actually really want to be
part of it but i also would one more
thing i would put on you is like people
should have the right to know the
results
so if you participated in a study tell
people what came out of that study
like most people participate in a
clinical trial and they have no idea
what happened
like isn't that crazy like i just
again i find it totally insulting like
don't treat me like a human subject
treat me like a partner
hi i'm harshit and i'm from india i'm
studying uh
business here
i want to understand uh how
you have used
or maybe how you have insights from
genetics on racial inequality
yeah we
i mean look looking at
um
looking at diversity i mean so it's a
question like there's there's lots of
complexity to your question like i would
say a couple things like one when we
started 23 meet we never expected that
we were going to be in the dialogue
about race
like we got into it for research and all
these things and like suddenly we're
about redefining
race we absolutely can see
um like we had one really interesting
publication where we asked people the
definition of african-american
and you can see
how people in the south might have 10
african dna and they do not identify as
african-american and you have people in
seattle who have zero percentage
african dna and they identify as
african-american so even defining
like what you are in your environment
where you are like it's super
complicated so there's absolutely
aspects that i think 23 me can have an
impact on
by helping understand you know genetic
ancestry
and likelihood to respond to medication
or likelihood to have an issue so for
instance there's someone named carlos
bustamante at ucsf and he does
phenomenal research in the latino
population
and asthma and he has seen like there's
certain medications that people should
never take
in the latino population but why are
they prescribed
and you have another example where in
hawaii the state of hawaii does not
allow the sale of plavix
like plavix is again it's a well-known
it's an anti-clotting drug and it's
because so many people in the state
don't respond to the medication so i
think one way like again it's racial and
health inequity is like is a huge issue
but i think one thing that you can
actually start to do is really
understand like not racial profiling
people but really understand your
genetic ancestry and what the mutations
are that you have and then whether or
not you have a predisposition for a
condition and should you be managed in a
different way or whether or not you have
a predisposition to like not respond or
likely to respond to a medication
so i do think there's a ton of
opportunity to have um improvement and
again you know racial profiling is the
only
you know it's it's it's the last area
where it's acceptable is in healthcare
like it's the first line of every
medical record you know 45 year old
white male comes in
like it's it's that's something i think
that we actually really have the
opportunity of changing
hi how's it going my name is jamas
like neil i'm also a md mba student
i worked in a huntington's disease
clinic for a year before medical school
and a lot of times the genetic results
that they would get was some of the most
devastating news they could ever hear in
their entire life and uh how would you
respond to people who believe 23 and me
should have a more thorough informed
consent process before releasing
information about like bracha one
mutations for instance
and then do you foresee a future where
people might push
to have patients act on some of the
information they receive and how are you
preparing for that
once those treatments are available
yeah i think
so again it goes to some of the
paternalistic questions
um i think
that you can absolutely have
a great
informed consent online
and
i think that's the kind of thing it's
like it should not be a debate
it's about data
like generate data where you ask people
to fill out the online consent and you
ask them to go through counseling and
then you have them answer those
questions like can you understand it so
we've done a lot of work about like our
people understanding what they are
getting
so i would argue that having an online
consent and making sure is potentially
even better
so for instance 23andme has a you go
through a number of consents like you
can't sign up accidentally it's a hard
process
reports like the alzheimer's braca for
breast cancer are behind an additional
layer of consent
so you have to click through and there's
a video that talks about what
potentially happens
there's all kinds of resources about
like hey here's the information you
might learn
this is what to expect and we see people
pause on health and not everyone wants
to know health and to your point on
huntington's um
the information is real like it's it's
it's meaningful for people but
huntington's is a is a is a slightly
different story because you can't do
anything about it
versus in braca at a certain age you can
like you can find out that um you know
you are high risk and get a prophylactic
mastectomy and overectomy um
and we've seen people like we have
thousands of customers who've now gotten
this
and we can see that you know 20 to 30
percent of our customers never would
have qualified
under existing research under existing
insurance guidelines so
i would argue that healthcare
has huge limitations because we have not
enabled broad access
and so saying that you can't get this
information until you have a one-to-one
in-person kind of interaction
only puts up barriers to access
like healthcare
like for me also the fundamental premise
and actually learned this i would spend
a lot of time investing in india
healthcare will never be like accessible
to all if it's dependent upon a
one-to-one interaction
like that like that right there should
be a good concept for all of you to run
on like it's not
you can't really improve care for people
unless we find ways to automate it more
and more
and so that has to happen and the first
company i ever invested in talk about
things that were too early it was a pap
smear company called neuromedical
it was one of the first ai companies
that i'd ever seen this is back in 1996
and they would take pap smears the
majority of which are normal and they'd
run them through the machine and then
they would isolate here's the top 20
percent that we need a pathologist to
look at and the company got taken down
by the pathologists like how dare you
automate our job
but the reality is like you can't have
scalable solutions in healthcare
if you don't have automation in some
ways like i asked my kids something like
all of you here like you probably don't
remember like when i was little and i
wanted to book a hotel in paris i had to
like set my
alarm and like wake up and call and like
talk to a human
like that's how it worked and like now
we're all totally spoiled like you go
online you can just book like it's all
automated like we never talk to people
and so like healthcare has to go more
and more in that direction and then save
like the really expensive presses
precious resources for people who really
really need
care
we have time for one more
hi i'm brianna i'm a geneticist and
actually a law student here um and so
talking about privacy um
and consent the thing that's different
about genetic information it's it's not
just about you it's about your family so
how do you think about your
responsibility for community consent or
familial consent in and community and
familial understanding of the data that
you collect yeah that that is also
that's a great question and it's a huge
complexity here
um
so we have gone with the hypothesis like
it's your
you
it's your dna it's your right to learn
about yourself but there are absolutely
consequences
and so for instance your mother might
not want to learn that
if she's a carrier for broncha
and you could get tested and find out
that you have
you know two copies
and therefore it's a hundred percent
deterministic like your mother hasn't
um
and we've seen that instance
um and we see this i would say what's
interesting again i love all the md's in
here and it'll be super fun we should
chat more later um
the the part that we don't get lots of
consternation and concern about about
health reports like our customers we
find are mostly like they're okay like
they they like a bronco report is not
fun
um to get but like they can handle all
this information and we've proven that
now in spades the part that no one
anticipates
is that
their parent is not their parent or
their sibling is not their sibling
and
that has real
you know if you have the access to your
genetic information you're going to
learn things about your entire family
and so i don't think that there is a
realistic world of group consent
i think the reality is like you own the
right to your own body
but we absolutely try to educate people
like that your information has
consequences
but i would say
when no one ever thinks it's them
that is not related to
a family member like there's no much
like and we have an additional consent
form like that is just always a surprise
for people but it's it's it's a very
real and very tricky aspect of 23andme
is that you're not just related to
like your immediate family like this
whole room is genetically connected
and so any number like you would
probably take some percentage of this
room and kind of connect everybody
so i totally real and that's in some
ways there's there's the inspiring part
for research
in that like we really are all in this
together so like if you want to solve
like the mystery of the human genome and
you want to solve you know like like the
genetics of various disease and what
like what does it really mean to be well
it is within the power of all of us
coming together
but there's absolutely has to be some of
the ethics and like the consent of like
how are we actually all getting together
and that's why i said like there's and
stanford is like again hank who who is
again engaged with us quite a bit um but
there's really interesting questions
around this around ethics and that's why
again i'm eternally grateful to
joanna mountain when she came from
stanford like she was absolutely a
thought leader in ethics and like when i
always think about the difference
between 23andme and other companies like
facebook didn't start with like a
consent form
like i know they have a research team
and other things but like there's no
consent that's part of it like 23 me
from day one
had consent and engaged with ethicists
and like really thought through
and recognize there's consequences
but in some ways like the what the
guiding principle for 23andme is
transparency and choice
and whether it's like transparency in in
yourself it's like choice whether you
want to get your genetic information
choice if you want to participate in
research choice if you don't want to do
all these things like and i think that's
one of the issues i have in healthcare
it's like most times you're not provided
choice and you're not provided
transparency
well thank you anne for your leadership
and your wisdom and thank you all for
coming that concludes you from the top
[Applause]
[Music]
you